you know the experience that MSNBC was
was eye-opening they notified me that I
was no longer fit with the network
escorted me from the premises I asked
them I walked right up to them and I
said hey why is it that I am such a
misfit I am in fact I told them not such
a nitwit
why don't I fit it why don't I fit in
I don't life is barely a cycle of
seasons for me ESPN was a seasoned MSNBC
was a season my dermatitis was a season
but you wouldn't light fourth of July
fireworks for Easter or hang your
stockings by the chimney with care on
Hallows Eve more commonly referred to as
Halloween that's because it would not be
appropriate for the season so goes the
seasons of life and I live by
[Applause]
via the split from MSNBC was was neutral
was a little unexpected little rough
wouldn't you true after that you know my
options were available to anything
it's like someone said Oh Keith here's a
map pick one so I did I dabbled in the
UH the conservative community course
ground zero for that is hello Bar
Mitzvah for Joey Berkowitz I remember
when I reached the age of thirteen the
world was my oyster
filled with miraculous wonders wedding
before me and myriad adventures that
would bring me in a path to hmm what's
seatback what's that Conservative
Political Action Conference dear
folks it would appear that my agent is
the worst person in the world but while
I have you here I would like to clear up
a couple of things if you've been
following the news cycle you've noticed
that I've recently left MSNBC to pursue
pastors in that have a greener shade
I've rediscovered my passion for music
in the form of DJing for parties bar
mitzvahs weddings which of course means
that I am a jockey of disks one who
parties in a nature of which is hearty
and the finest in the West Village
of course after leaving home assemble
you see I tried to search for a platform
that would allow for me to reach a
higher viewership and so I went with Al
Gore's Current TV website that's on the
interwebs
I couldn't be more content with the
arrangement I am generously reimbursed
in both carbon credits and maybelline
gift cards so
you know that experience could have been
more pleasant looking back but so goes
the season of life rumors surrounding my
departure here at uh MSNBC so I'd like
to take a moment to clear them up
I was not fired I instead decided to
leave quit while you're on top my father
told me like Rocky Marciano leave when
you are at your peak and let's be honest
once you've cracked the top 12 in the
cable news race there's very much little
left to prove you know I understand the
need to adapt to evolve if one would a
quoting mr. Charlie Darwin ah that's why
people can now communicate with me
directly at HTTP colon backslash
backslash twitter.com slash Keith
Oberman
it's a vast new information superhighway
space-age and uh you know it's it's
taken me a little away from my roots
this whole thing forced me to find that
fire back inside of me seek out some
some help
thank you for coming check out problem
so how do we do this
the stuff we email why are we gonna look
are we supposed to look at each other
yeah right it really awkward so I don't
know much time set or me now
[Music]
so you learn a little bit about
investigative journalism I dabble yes
okay well what I do is pick a target who
are you gonna cut it
next up is study your target my guru
sure I wonder if that's one of many
Wikipedia we call it in the booths that
can only get you so far bit sure
but the next thing is you have to find a
means of recording your target mmm in
illegal activity mmm so you want to get
a hidden camera recording devices will
write at these are recording devices
silica flip flip flip camera will you
it's amazing it no no you want a camera
that is you can hide in your glasses
something you can hide in your front
lapel pocket maybe a necklace thank you
for taking the time you can have a seat
thank you well I have this idea and I
was told you're the man - I guess sort
of facilitated I would like to send in a
hooker and - no no here's a twist into
the Vatican and we're gonna get the Pope
and I believe all the Cardinals because
in my estimation their whole bunch of
well I so I see where you're headed and
you had me at pimp and prostitute well
thank you pimp and prostitute they could
be fake they could be you know I get
that all the time you wouldn't believe I
realize you would
no call me Jared you are his
doppelganger there's no daddy no no no I
know I get that over tears if you're
gonna do these type of undercover stings
I highly recommend that you don't go in
with a video camera taped around the
necklace it is fairly obvious my
Security's been compromised that is a
huge digital camera tape to a green
Mardi Gras necklace I'm just following
your directions okay that's what you
specifically said to do necklace hidden
camera in a necklace hidden it's in the
necklace right here it's on the necklace
okay you know what this stapler has
hidden camera what you can't see it can
you see it it's a stapler
is Malkin thank you for taking the time
you look lovely so I hear there's some
footage of violin outraged at a tea
party and I know you have it what would
one go to procure you think I have
footage of Milan Tea Party members
you've got to be kidding yes no I know
it's out there you know beat up in
African American gentleman AHA I think
you've got that backwards Keith no no my
sources indicated and it's definitely
somewhere here around yeah well I don't
have anything like that and neither does
anybody else and why are you putting
that stapler in my face no that's not a
stable yes it is yes yes get it out of
my face
[Music]
I don't feel badly at all property
rights my property rights he's lucky I
didn't shoot him Sam you know what
really I'd really rather not say I am
the worst person in the world that is
utter doubt maybe investigative
journalism isn't your calling maybe you
should try something else
not baseball I've always liked playing
baseball usually you have to be younger
a little more agile fit this is a bad
day
[Music]
[Music]